what are the different ways a writer can
find an agent it's a question I get
asked all the time
and there are a number of ways one is
enter a contest and come in first
if your quarter finalist
that's not going to do anything
and as I said before if you're a quarter
finalist in the McGee Film Festival
nobody is looking at that
if you are in a very prestigious
competition and you come in first or
second agents and managers will find you
and the annoying thing is is that agents
say when you say how does somebody get
an agent they say don't worry when
you're ready we'll find you and there's
a lot of Truth in that no matter how
annoying it is
so that's one
another way is if it's television and
you can get into one of the network
fellowships they will introduce you to
agents and managers
if you can find a mentorship program
they will introduce you to their agents
or managers if you
do a one woman one man one person show
and you put it up it has a fantastic
reaction that's how fleabag came about
they'll find you
um another way my daughter who's a
comedy writer an aspiring comedy writer
one of her best friends did a video that
went viral
and she was wrapped within a week and
they keep inviting her to go back to
Saturday Night Live and apply to be a
writer there so if you make a Big Splash
in social media that is a way to do it
knowing somebody who knows somebody who
can get your script to an agent or
manager or an agent or manager's
assistant
is one way to do it
I used to say don't bother with this but
cold queries can work I've now had three
mentees and a client who wrote fabulous
letters cold queries emails
and they made their themselves so
appealing and the log line for one of
their scripts so appealing that the
manager or agent said I'd like to read
your script
and then
they had a meeting with them because the
script was so good and they got wrapped
another way is and this is hard if
you're not in the business is to have a
job working in the business even if it's
as a PA somewhere because you'll meet
somebody who will know somebody who will
know somebody who will know somebody who
can get your script in front of an agent
or a manager
another way is to have a podcast these
days podcasts wow that is super
successful they'll find you
um the easiest way is to already be
making money as a screenwriter because
agents love to poach their competitions
clients
and those are the ways those are the
ways
so with the people that queried
and sent these letters out how did they
know the names and where did they find
the contact information how they
actually get the contact information
IMDb Pro has contact information for
agents and managers I recommend that
people look for a manager first
there's so many more of them than there
are agents and the ones just starting
out are often willing to take
newbies and and sort of invest in them
and one way to do it is to look at your
favorite movie your favorite television
shows
go to IMDb look up their name and see
who represents them and then go to that
person's contact page and that's how you
do it what should a new writer expect
from a meeting with an agent in a
meeting
if you're a hot commodity the manager or
agent it's like being on a date when
somebody wants to get you in bed they
will tell you anything how beautiful you
are how handsome you are how much they
love you
what you should be thinking about in
that meeting if you're a hot commodity
is
ask them very clearly where do you see
my career in five years and how will you
help me get there the thing to remember
is if you go with this person they work
for you
you want to make sure that they've read
your material and they get who you are
they really understand who you are as a
writer and they get your Vibe and that
your Vibes match
um you may not you may want a super
aggressive agent or that may not be your
style and you want somebody who's super
hard working and ambitious but not super
aggressive
you can expect them to ask you what you
want in a relationship with a manager
you can expect them to ask
who do you know in the business because
the more people you know the easier it
is for them to do their job they might
ask you what are your favorite shows
what are your favorite movies they may
ask you what is your sweet spot as a
writer what do you like to write what
are you great at writing they will
definitely ask you
what else do you have in your portfolio
besides what they read for you to get to
that meeting
that's probably about it they'll they'll
make small talk to get you to now that's
if you're a hot commodity and it's all
your choice because you're meeting with
five different managers and you get to
decide it's really who you Vibe with and
who has a track record in getting their
clients work
if you're new and you're not yet a hot
commodity
you should be prepared to tell them what
else you have in your portfolio you
should be prepared to tell them what
your career Ambitions are you should be
prepared to tell them
who you know in the business and the
ways that you meet people they're going
to want to know that you should be
prepared to ask them who are your other
clients that I might talk to
they may take umbrage of that and if
they do that's not the person for you
um
you should be prepared to ask them
how do they see you getting to the next
level in your career and how can they
help you do it
they may ask you how often how long does
it take you to write a script and be
prepared to be honest with that answer
so unlike a first date where
you wouldn't say you know when when are
we setting our wedding in an agent
meeting you would be very upfront about
this is what I expect and what can I
expect from you would that be a little
bit too fast too soon
well you don't probably have a lot
unless you're that hot commodity you
don't have a lot of shots with
an agent or manager you probably have
one meeting with them I'm not suggesting
you come in guns blazing
I think you come in and you're
complimentary to them and you say you
know I would love to work with you I it
would be fantastic I'd love to ask you a
couple of questions
and say it in a humble way but ask those
questions
okay so there's direction to the meeting
it's not just you're showing up and you
have an actual plan yes you want to
think ahead now sometimes
and it's not very often this may just be
a meet and greet get to know you see
what they think of you
um and it's not what we call a signing
meeting it's really just a get to know
you they read something of yours they
liked it they they want to know more
about you and then it's really about
having a relationship a conversation
with them like you would with a friend
or a new person who you wanted to be
friends with
but if it turns to business be prepared
to ask those questions okay have that in
your back pocket absolutely what are
some red flags a new writer should be
aware of when meeting with an agent if
the person is a jerk
if they haven't read you
if they're blowing smoke
if they're not transparent about the
type of people they represent if they're
late to the meeting if they talk at you
the whole time if they're just being
blustery if they don't ask you about
yourself and again if they haven't read
your work if they don't have an opinion
about your work
these are red flags
how do we know someone's blowing smoke
if they tell you you're fabulous you're
fabulous you're fabulous and you've only
written run script they're probably
blowing smoke if
they say oh yeah I can get you a meeting
with Spielberg I can get you a meeting
with JJ Abrams you need to that's a red
flag because they don't know you enough
yet and if they could get you those
meetings
you're probably not meeting with the
people that can get you those meetings
when you're starting out
talking out someone versus talking with
them yes oh pet peeve
they just talk about themselves it's a
wall of words they talk talk they don't
give you any time to they never take a
breath for you to say something they're
just talking about themselves and
they're talking Non-Stop and they're not
making eye contact and they're not
pausing and they're not reading the room
they don't care about you
so they're not you you see they're not
picking up on social cues right okay
they take themselves so seriously they
love the sound of their voice that's not
somebody who's going to help you because
if they're that way with you they're
going to be that way with decision
makers and that turns decision makers
off
what if an agent rejects a writer that's
sad but move on to the next one
but we're sensitive artists Carol we we
we feel things this was our biggest
painful it's painful
um I worked at a job where my contract
didn't get picked up for a second part
of it I was so devastated I ate ice
cream for days I bought shoes I felt
terrible
and then I moved on and my husband has a
great way of looking he said wallow in
it wallow in your pain wallow in the
disappointment give yourself three days
to feel enough stay in bed
watch stupid television
and then move on
unless you want to give up forever right
then and don't do that this is part of
the business
feel it
acknowledge it experience it
give yourself the space to do that and
then move on to the next